taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food Tasties
welcome to t-a-s-d-e Buds and buddies
you might take these Tasties is a new
one but I like saying my little Tasties
yeah Tasties and buddies peace are you
maybe the Buddies of the boys and the
Tasties of the gals
why do you gotta gender it let people
live it's true
but you could we could do shirts are you
a tasty I'm a tasty I'm a buddy
oh okay that's fun
hey happy Halloween everybody uh it's
Halloween uh we should just put this up
like randomly and not make it the
Halloween episode just that would be
very funny
we have uh we have our battle today is a
worst candy bar or worst candy bar it's
the Almond Joy versus The Three
Musketeers I will be teamed Musketeers
uh Sal will be Teen Mom enjoy we'll get
to it when we get to it but uh that's
that's what's happening today on today's
when you say team Almond Joy it means I
like Almond Joy you're battling the
worst so you're actually team Almond Joy
no no I'm confused I think the Three
Musketeers is not good and you think the
Almond Joy is not good yeah and I think
the um we'll get to it is it almond it's
almond isn't it the L is silent no
salmon it's like salmon almond no almond
are you sure about that I thought it was
almond I mean I'm not sure about
anything I'm sitting here in a hot dog I
know actually this is hot is it yeah
this is breathing very well but it's not
the most comfortable thing to have
around your head this is hot yeah you're
not hot not at all oh I'm dying in here
let's hear what the uh correct
pronunciation on the Internet is of
almond
do you hear an L yeah
can you can you go to the phonetics uh
pronunciation the way it says it on a
like underneath the definition
how to pronounce almond the right way
both almond and Alm end are correct but
both that both of those are L's
what do you mean
um oh oh almond or the second one um
that's insinuating and it's it's
recognizing the L no it's the L is
missing AME oh I see what you mean amen
amen is the L silent denominator no it's
not saying both click on the link that
says how to pronounce I'm in the right
way
it's saying all three are accepted
okay oh was that part of that article I
got you yeah all right well then touche
douche but salmon salmon is not you
can't say I I always laugh when I hear
someone say Salman no salmon is nuts
salmon in fact that's a Seinfeld salmon
Rusty yeah when he goes he goes Phil
bass bass salmon it's salmon not salmon
you idiot yeah yeah
that's a great one uh oh America's
favorite Halloween candy is already
ranked
I will say though when you get into
Halloween candies happy Halloween
everybody when you get into Halloween
candies though there are candies that
come into play that are not in anyone's
regular rotation they only get they only
get pushed during Halloween pretty
interesting it's a state map in each
State's favorite Halloween candy no [ __ ]
um the mighty Venetia brought in many
candy bars today some of which are
bangers we gotta we got an extra large
Reese's cup over there let's put these
let's sprinkle these all over here
um but I actually on air because we're
arguing worse candy bars I pulled we
both pulled
runner-ups I agree with for out of the
selection that that she brought of like
other ones that are like who gives a
[ __ ] candy bars
yeah today's attitude
um I will say that
I out of the out of the things we hit
the pool we had to choose from I think
the biggest scam is the Three Musketeers
right we'll get to that okay I'm saying
though in the meantime yeah we pulled
some other ones that we think are like
waste
yeah get off my shelf candy bars yeah
like I'd like to taste them with you
okay so
no well listen candy right so like some
there's some candy bars I don't like I
don't see many here that I don't like
but I wouldn't get this and I think it's
a scam I wouldn't get the Hershey white
chocolate with cookies which is these
favorite candy bar of all time it's
insane
white chocolate
when I was little I liked it then I
didn't like it then I'm like when I'm in
the mood for it
the actual cookies and cream crunch
inside this to me is Van Hagar it's like
what are you guys doing man you mean the
comic strip no Van Halen when Hagar came
in okay
this isn't even van Hagar this is Van
what was the third singer Helsing no
remember the guy remember when they
brought the guy in from extreme to sing
for Van Halen on that third thing I was
like guys stop yeah this to me is that I
was like Hershey what are you doing
don't see it as an innovation no what's
it called what's the proper name of it
cookies and cream
Hershey's white chocolate cookies and
cream that's on the regular shelf all
the time yeah yeah the regular that all
of these they just the only first of all
oh God sorry no no I think that that's
similar to Crunch don't you and you like
crunch
oh the message
crunch version no what are you nuts well
this is this is rice crisp like Crispies
and those are I think like almost like
the equivalent of like an Oreo pieces
maybe first of all I want to point out
about the Hershey's cookies and cream
it's such an odd color that it starts to
look blue and they even made the
packaging have blue highlights because
it matches it the the candy bar looks
blue which is off it has a hue to it
I'll give you that I I miss I miss by
the way I'm looking at all these I miss
old school candy bar wrappers like the
old school crunch was wrapped it was
wrapped in foil and then there was
another paper wrapper over it and you
broke it out very very Willy Wonka yeah
like everything now is just in these
baggies I'm sure maybe it's cheaper and
keeps it fresher but
all right all right cookies I always
think people do not like for us to they
want us to eat but I think they're wrong
I mean that tastes like an Oreo so I
don't know what to say that because that
tastes good you know what I'll say to it
I'm taking another piece yeah I don't
like it you really don't like this I
actually this just made me say don't put
it on the list it tastes like an all
cream Oreo I don't like it it just
tastes like sugar
it just tastes like sugar to me it
tastes like that's why I don't like
Krispy Kreme Donuts they just taste like
sugar
there's no there's no genese quad to it
I don't know man that that
was good
um with you you turned me I'm not into
it
B you're stupid
second is the payday this thing to me is
just an insult a candy bar it's just an
insult to put canned to put peanuts in
the form of a candy bar and go look it's
candy it's almost like a health food
trick yeah get a bunch of penises stick
together it's bold to go into the market
of chocolate and then not have chocolate
and say this is where we want to live as
well why don't we not have chocolate to
make the peanuts the Crux of it yeah the
peanuts or the ball it's not like
there's peanuts inside the outer layer
they put it on the outside it's all
peanut it's 100 peanut all the time
isn't it
but I gotta be honest with you now again
this is one that I wouldn't pick up off
the shelf but if and when the time comes
especially at Halloween these are
some of these candy bars this is always
a mini in Halloween that's when I have
it I only have it on Halloween just like
the hundred grand 100 Grand would be
nothing without Halloween I gotta be
honest with you no one's taking a
full-size hundred grand off the shelf
but they are throwing it in in the can
are you gonna be honest with you yeah
that's fantastic
baby whatever it is
it's folks Joe to Rosa here telling you
to come on out and see me live because
it's a hot dog of a time I'm doing my
new one-man show I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden all over the place November
8th for the New York Comedy Festival
here in New York New York on December
8th uh we are doing we'll see you in
hell live in St Petersburg Florida but
then on the 9th and 10th I will be doing
the one-man show I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden uh Austin Texas January 13th
and 14th uh January 20th and 21st
governors in Levittown we are adding new
dates all the time for venue info and
tickets Please go to jodarosainfo.com
also Joey roses is now open seven days a
week starting at 11 30 a.m every day
the man was too high had to expand hours
expand days come on out and see us seven
days a week 11 30 a.m every day
joeyrosesnyc.com
all right guys the Impractical Jokers
are back on the road after three years
we just announced the tour is called the
drive drive drive tour tickets are
available
impracticaljokerslive.com all cities
across the country we start off in
Pittsburgh at the PPG Paints Arena we'll
be coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island so
on and forth so forth everything's on
sale right now and then uh that starts
in February before that my only two
months left to touring are November and
December November uh 11th Knoxville
November 12th two in Atlanta Georgia one
just sold out says you want to get
tickets get it to the second show 13th
November 13th in Alabama and then we got
November 18th in Louisville and November
19th in Evansville December will be
California and Florida check it all out
right now at savocano comedy.com
everything's on sale merch is available
there for everything pick up some merch
I'll see you on the road
peanuts and caramel and I it might have
peanut butter let's see it tastes like
what you want peanut butter will tastes
like
that's really good this is
a scroll of people that want us to eat
on here
this is good yeah I enjoy this this is
very nice yeah I like it I like it as an
alternative to Chocolate I really like
that and I can't eat chocolate
the candy bars I get I get like my weird
reaction thing and I got it actually
from the Hershey that actually cleanse
the palette
I think I have a candy bar I can get now
I'm gonna get the payday because I can't
have the chocolate payday is also a
pretty fun name
what do you think has the best Twix on
the wrapper sorry
I can't believe I just I was covering I
was covering not thinking
you could
don't do me like that
all right you won't taste this one
I've never extracted out of the wrapper
without like [ __ ] you're probably
getting all your germs on it here's what
I'll do I'll split it
I'll just break a piece okay like it's a
KitKat who am I breaking a piece hold on
now hold on let me say this Baby Ruth
I have never had one of these I've never
had a baby ruth the only reason I knew
of Baby Ruth was because of Goonies
Caddyshack no Goonies
remember of course oh yeah yeah but also
Baby Ruth was the was what people
mistook [ __ ] that was in the pool in
Caddyshack yes and then the guy eats it
what a classic movie gag the fat Pool
Cleaner picking up the the and eating it
the only better candy gag I've ever seen
in a movie is in Police Academy too
it might be three when Mahoney which one
is Citizens on patrol I forget I think
it's two
uh
those can't hold up right I got I'm
gonna you know what dude I they're okay
I want to watch one of those and see
what's up oh wait no that's four no it's
not four what's two the one where Bobcat
Goldthwait is the bad guy it's not was
that the one with the blue
um the blue
assignment I think it's in their first
assignment I might be wrong maybe it is
citizen Patrol but Mahoney who's played
by Steve Gutenberg gets paired with the
fat guy who's the new cop okay
[Laughter]
there's an open Nestle's crunch sitting
on the bed of a truck and the guy goes
look at this somebody just left a
perfectly good Destiny crunch here
bite out of it
and Mahoney goes
I know man you're not gonna eat that are
you the guy goes no wonder they left it
here there's ants all over it and he
brushes off
foreign
candy joke uh all right so can you read
the ingredients in this
chocolate caramel and peanuts I believe
that's it
yeah oh and no no no nuke
nougat and nougat this is essentially a
Snickers bar
whoa whoa whoa
peanuts
chocolate
this tastes nothing like a Snickers bar
I've never had one the portions are
different I think Snickers go is hotter
on the caramel let's taste it I mean it
really does look like a turd yeah
I think this is like I taste this and it
has all for me a Baby Ruth I taste it
again only I have it on Halloween when
it's but I tasted it out it's not good
right yeah no because it's so weird that
it has all the things that are good in
other candy bars like it has all the
right ingredients Snickers is delicious
it has chocolate peanut nougat and
caramel it should taste good but then
but then it doesn't and I'm sorry to the
people at Babe Ruth
that I'm supporting families and stuff
like I don't mean like that's the worst
candy bar that I like it I just that's
the worst candy bar everything you may
not want to bite it it doesn't taste
right something's weird about it
something's weird something's weird
together to make something greater than
the sum
of their parts I almost wish you were
arguing for that but you don't like it
either
should I not eat this son he's I know
what it tastes like
something's off something's real as soon
as you start chewing it's off
right how could I have the same
ingredients as the Snickers
different people are making it
um
something's off
that should be their slogan
baby room something's off
um it does not taste like this and has
the same ingredients it's not great we
should tell the audience Joe just ate
more of the payday
Joe's got a mouthful not
it's a mouthful of nut over there okay
I'm thrilled about the payday
this is a big day yeah it's a Payday
now I've been off candy bars because of
my chocolate thing I have a candy bar I
can eat now and enjoy it I am happy for
you genuinely inside yeah really yes I
am are you really why wouldn't I be I
can't tell if you mean it I do mean it
all right
all right
all right we'll put these aside what
else is going on before we get to the
rush and then by the way
I also wanted to
Mr Goodbar you you immediately were like
you're crazy that is a classic yeah
you're crazy
is it yes that's that's that's a old
school Banger that's still around with
no advertising by the way nobody
advertises Mr Goodman but nobody
advertises baby Mary Janes they're still
around nobody wants it good point good
point
I I would say I would say Mr Goodbar you
know and he you didn't know this you
don't buy the bags you never come across
the bags of the mini Hershey bars and
it's four in a bag and it's Mr Goodbar
it's it's uh it's crackle crackle is a
bomb which is
it's the exact same thing
um but it's not Nestle
crackle's the bomb and then you got um
the dark chocolate Hershey and the
regular Hershey bar original and I gotta
tell you every time I sound off in the
comments but every time one of those
assortment of the mini Hershey bars are
put out at a party and anything anywhere
I see him the Mr goodbars are the hot
commodity out of that four are those
this is what bothers me and I showed
this to you before we started and then I
go dark chocolate sex well why does good
bar get its own name its own fancy
advertising and rapper and all that
stuff and Hershey with almonds it's just
that Hershey with almonds give this a
name and in in a in its own color
wrapper and and and its own I think it
just came from a different place right I
mean when they made the Mr Goodbar it
was just called a Mr Goodbar it's only
recently that they're like well and then
later on I think it's like Hershey's Mr
Goodbar I think what they were doing
here was they were trying to expand the
original Hershey bar to have
other choices and version that was
always just Mr Goodbar from the get and
I will tell you this I'm feeling the
back of this
so Mike gripe with Hershey's with
almonds
is that there was never enough almonds I
don't like when they put almond slivers
in it and stuff this is whole almonds do
you remember I thought there's an almond
in every bite of a Hershey with almonds
literally sound like like copy from a
commercial I'm serious now feel the back
of that thing it feels like it has
tumors
that's what I know this thing does feel
like it has like like it should go get
checked yeah
it's it has a lot actually which I'm I I
think that maybe they just restarted
doing that because my biggest gripe
would I would buy it and go like this
and be like there's nothing in this
thing did you as a kid and you guys as
kids did you sell chocolate bars for
school or yes you did did you go to
Catholic School
to public school and you still sold the
bars was it Superior chocolate
and it was it the one with a free
hamburger on the wrapper
still had it so they came in three bars
regular almonds or toffee or whatever it
was right they were a dollar each room a
little and when we were little they were
this size and they were a dollar each
now they're half the size without a
doubt at least half the size as they
used to be they'd give us a cardboard
box that had 40 of them in there or 50
and you'd break it in half and the two
halves end up having like cardboard
handles like a Happy Meal yeah and then
you'd walk with them like a suitcase
full of chocolate bars and you'd sell
them
family and friends but door to door
because it was prizes they did that
right they're incentivizing children to
go door to door selling sugar
to other children families to get prizes
it's crazy and what was the rub there
was a rub on that somebody was getting
somebody was taking it was always a kid
you could never beat because his dad
brought him to the office and he worked
at a Forbes 500 company and somebody was
like I'll take 500 bars but I mean and
that kid got the bike it wasn't as
simple as hey you go sell these candy
bars and you get to win prizes there was
somebody benefiting from that that
wasn't you or the customer is my point I
think Superior chocolate
they sold them for charity though wasn't
it I never saw it because I didn't grow
up in this it's very similar to the Girl
Scouts yes yes yes they sell for charity
but then they also when we were little
they every one of them every single one
of them the rapper was a coupon for a
free McDonald's hamburger every single
wow and the place was called Superior
chocolate and I tell you this at the
time now they've like everything else
they've tried to get a better price
point to get less less good ingredients
the superior chocolate bars that we sold
as a kid was this thick and there was
like a hundred lumps of filaments on the
back and it was the best tasting
chocolate better than like it was so
good I remember the generic I don't
remember if we had Superior or not they
probably gave it a different name every
four states or whatever but I remember
the Almond version of what we sold was
excellent and you used to sell you know
I sometimes I would sell two three boxes
and then I'd say you know you get what
would you get I don't remember the
prizes but they weren't I never knew
this so I lived in New York though
because I didn't grow up in the city the
kids that would Hustle
they would just get candy yeah and walk
around and say like I'm selling this for
my basketball team and it was just so
they could profit off of candy yeah
which was such a brilliant thing yeah
um the uh oh I was gonna ask you
something ask I can't remember now
oh wait do you have Halloween plans
for me right now I'm on the fence okay
there's there's a couple of options but
I just I might be tied up I got you I we
should talk offline I don't know I I I I
gotta find out where this is going you
guys are you down to like Clown again or
yeah I got to figure it out for me I got
to figure out if I'll be involved I I'm
in a similar position I don't know if I
can go out to Halloween I'm really
trying to stick to this health thing
and go outside I cannot take you serious
right now
you're telling me you don't know I'm
trying to stick to this health thing you
have a processed meat head I'm just a
guy trying to cut the mustard right I
gotcha uh and it's been a real dog
but catch up I know and look let us let
us let us talk about all these things
okay wait you would put lettuce in a hot
dog though oh wait your lettuce sorry
come on man oh God what are you grilling
you're not gonna cut the mustard are you
grilling me oh
this is our 101st episode 101
congratulations thank you to all our
listeners I think we're now up to like
for subscribers on YouTube I think we're
approaching 300 000 Maybe
and uh and then of course on on Spotify
so thank you guys for supporting us 101
I mean who knew I mean like we got here
we broke 100 men it's really wild it's
been a really uh uh
it's been a really easy painless Journey
I'd like to sit here and say it was a
lot of work
but it was fun this painlessly for this
long I think is rare or at least it's
medium rare
yeah
well done my friend well done we planted
this game that what it deserves
we planned the seeds a couple years ago
and at this point you're right
[Music]
um listen I mean you're hot I know
you're really on a roll
I mean until we can't until someone
can't get one it's over
that might be out I'm relishing in this
I really am
the uh listen so
ah Christ I forget I got nothing yeah no
you were telling me that you uh well try
to stick to the health thing I can't
I just don't know that I can go out on
Halloween like this soon to start close
to starting I don't know that I can go
out on I am allowed to at some point
have fun again it's just a little too
soon I think to cash in on that and
Halloween is I'm ready to take that
chance again what do you think Barry
Manilow I think that you go out and just
you make sure you don't do the things
you're not supposed to do but you enjoy
the um the night and your friends do you
think there's any way to enjoy the night
and your friends when it's Halloween and
everybody is getting shit-faced and
you're just kind of hanging out I don't
think that that's possible you think so
I do think so I think it's going to take
a slight mental preparation from you
where you're gonna say I'm gonna go out
right now with a pet my step and a good
attitude I'm gonna have some laughs and
I'm actually going to prove to myself
that I could have a fun night sober and
I honestly I think there's no better
night to try that than running down the
streets with your friends in costumes I
mean the fun is there it's built in I
mean you can have fun you could do it I
would say like do something like just
have something in your hand like have a
self-ser or something that you could
kind of sip on or whatever you know
you're not gonna you're not gonna do any
weed or anything you want to that's the
thing I don't you know there's no weed
man why don't you make a life change
because I I don't like it let's break
through that Joe I know I know I've
thought about that like maybe I can get
through it but I just don't like it I
don't like the way maybe you can do
something especially in public maybe you
could do something in the ballpark of
weed
now Kratom yeah yeah no one got that
dude I gotta tell you Ballpark Franks I
bruised
I did that all at
um I did that all at skank Fest you did
weed no I did nothing I just did what
you're saying you said it was a great I
had a great time but I was doing shows
sure very very different pretty much
doing shows it was
I'd film that do a set do a set oh God
if you went up like to the stand with
that costume on and did a set or do it I
wouldn't I'm not committing to it
because I'm lazy but I would do it I
have no I have no problem doing it I got
the clip yeah yeah yeah
but no I'm not even kidding man I
bruised my rib at skank Fest
um and my doctor it really really hurt
when I got home to the point where I
couldn't like sleep every time I moved
it was terrible it feels fine now every
pain is bad my doctor gave me oxy
not cotton not the bad one the other one
oxycodone whatever
you say the same thing no they're
different he goes
no but he goes take these so you can
sleep at night because you're you need
to relax the muscle I took them for one
day
even that
of the effects of that even that I had
to go lay down when I didn't want to go
to bed and be like you're cool you're
cool you're cool don't freak out don't
freak out I can't [ __ ] stand anymore
anything that takes over my senses that
quickly and that hard drinking is the
one thing I like because I feel like I
can control it and and then when you if
you do have too much
you either Brown out or you throw up or
you go I gotta go home I'm hungry or
whatever it is like your body's like
okay and it's not you feel like a
physical altercation from it but you do
not feel or hindrance rather but you do
not feel like
oh my God like what is happening and you
know like I get that you're used to it
you know how to do it you know how to
navigate alcohol yeah I I just I just
really hate it
I was running to get this Keith Robinson
tattoo
uh I was running out of uh the uh just
on a set and the comic her name's Ariel
she's really lovely a lovely person and
she's very funny
I don't mean to speak for I don't know I
just got a beer thrown at her Ariel no a
different version
she might go she might it might be that
I'm sorry I don't mean to genderize
anybody but anyway my point is is Ariel
is a very lovely person and and very
funny so
um Ariel was on stage and I was I was
like trying to get out of the showroom
you had to cut across the state like in
front of the stage to get out and it was
like linoleum or tile floor
and I was I squatted way down and I was
running because I wanted to make the
appointment why'd you squat because I
you had to cross in front of the stage I
didn't want to like construct and you
know I was trying to be as discreet as
possible and then of course this happens
there was a puddle of beer on the floor
you wiped out in front of the stage dude
yeah yeah
with a crowd watching dude people had to
like the show stopped like people think
like
people to like get me off the ground
dude dude I why I'm telling you I wiped
so bad I thought I thought I might have
broken my knee oh my God yeah which is
funny like I'm not trying to be sure you
know you know that's
that venue should have I mean it
shouldn't be a pool
start suing well what am I going to do
Sue Sue skank Fest I'm fine the value
right
it was it was a it was a simple thing it
was somebody clearly spilled a beer
during the the show
ah the answer is always soon yeah
yeah I know but uh did you fall because
it was neglect
I think it had just happened somebody
just spilled something and it was so
Jacoby and Myers what do you say to the
crowd that the [ __ ] what do you say
what's the first line of you dude no no
I wiped out yeah
Sue everybody I wiped out uh I wiped out
the entire crowd went oh and like people
were on the one left no dude it was bad
let me ask you a question do they were
they videotaping sets
they somebody got picked
excuse me somebody got pictures of me on
the ground but nobody has a video
I have pictures on my phone it would
have been wonderful
um
just no I know I I wish there was a
video too there wasn't
um
no and people like came up to me and
they're like bro are you okay can you
get up and I was like
and I I at first you're just doing the
thing we're like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] because I was just like you're so
embarrassed but then also too you don't
want to like make noises like you're in
pain
so you're just like trying to like win
knocked out of you no luckily
but I and then I interrupted her and
then she's on the Ariel's on stage going
like
are you okay like can you get up like it
was the worst case scenario Jesus of
course it was why would anything in my
life be a decent case scenario it's got
to be the worst case scenario can you
cut that whole thing of him in the hot
dog head and just use that for when we
need it please please
how great would have been if it was like
it was that was on Halloween weekend and
when you ran by you were in that outfit
when you fell
all bets are off all these guys were
standing over me and I can gender these
I know that the guys at skank Fest go is
go by guy have you guys heard about
Amazon Pharmacy yet the Amazon that
you're thinking has a pharmacy now and
you can get your prescriptions mailed
right to your door uh you know you don't
have to leave the house one thing I hate
doing is actually for real going to the
to Pharmacy and either I either for some
reason the pharmacy has different hours
in the the front of the store and it's
closed or I'm getting online and people
will listen to listen to what medicine I
need
um Amazon Pharmacy uh takes you time
they save you money and it keeps you
healthy day there's transparent pricing
so you know what you're paying before
and then Prime members can get up to 80
off their subscriptions prescription
subscriptions I messed that up but check
this out if you ever have any questions
or problems real pharmacists are
available at Amazon Pharmacy no matter
what time of day or night 24 7
medication delivered to your door so
there's no more rushing to the store a
pharmacy that works for your life with
meds delivered to your door it doesn't
get any better than that switch to
Amazon Pharmacy and save time save money
and stay healthy learn more at
amazon.com
buds that's amazon.com
buds amazon.com slash buds uh average
savings based on I'm not having a stroke
here they listed it three times average
savings based on usage and inside RX
data as compared to cash prices average
savings for all generics are 78 37 for
selected brand medications restriction
Supply guys I use butcher box ever since
I found them on our show uh better for
me than a local grocery store I'm not
one that really knows how to pick out
Meats per se and I never really know
what I want I don't want to go to the
grocery store and buy up to 14 pounds of
meat which is what you get with butcher
box which is a subscription service that
sends all these humanely raised organic
grass-fed different types of proteins to
your house pork raised crate free wild
caught free range you name it that's
what it is uh no antibiotics no hormones
get just what you want delivered to your
doorstep this free shipping in the
continental United States so it's free
to ship so there's no charge for
ordering it okay choose from a variety
of box options from ones that they
curate to ones that you can customize
and change your plan whenever you want
exclusive member deals so you save big
over your favorite Cuts this Recipe
Inspirations guides tips and hacks some
are even personalized uh it's a really
cool service you can stop it whenever
you want
um they have seasonal meals check it out
just check it out I'm sure you'll like
it the main course for Thanksgiving
dinner uh can sometimes be a main source
of stress not anymore right butcher box
is offering our listeners free turkey
with the first order so sign up today at
putyourbox.com tastebuds and use the
code taste buds to get one
10 to 14 pound turkey free with your
first box that's butcherbox.com taste
buds and use the code taste buds to
claim this deal and then you go your
Thanksgiving meal is off to a a start
they were sitting over me and they were
like dude can you get up and I was like
honestly I don't know because I go my
knee feels so weird right now
I feel like it's gonna give out if you
pick me up but I can't stand on it
myself do you think that was a sign from
a higher being that you weren't supposed
to get a Keith Robinson stinks tattoo
dude I went
I got to I got outside
uh Rebecca Trent one of The Producers
came up to me congratulations to
everybody over there too uh Christine
Rebecca Lewis and Lewis one another
successful event I know it's a beast to
do and uh she was really really cool
thing to do fans thank you to Christine
Rebecca and Louis and thank you to all
the skank fans but thank you also the
taste buds love we were getting it you
were telling me so amazing oh my God it
was so cool the whole event was so fun
right now
um uh so Rebecca Trent came up to me and
she's like oh my God are you okay and I
was like look I think I'll be fine but I
need ice
and I was like I need you to get me to
the tattoo place
I was like because I can barely walk
right now oh my God and it was the only
time right after it happened four people
that didn't see you probably didn't even
feel the tattoo because the aching from
the rest for people that didn't see it
happen it was the only time that this
happened four people that didn't see it
happen were like DeRosa can I get a pic
it was the only time I was like
dude I'm really sorry man I need a
minute like something just happens
that's all I said and they were very
cool and I hope I was nice but I tried
to be
and I just said to Rebecca I'm like I
have to get to this tattoo place I'm
limping you have to get me there please
and she was like no problem and she got
me there she got me sat down and then
she's like here's ice they brought me
ice and I got a special designated room
like wherever they were yeah they had a
tattoo one guy it wasn't like four
people okay how do you know that you can
trust the work
the guy that the main guy I'm blanking
on his name he's a guy that Jay knows
who's great okay a new test for a minute
and I just don't want to go in blind you
couldn't go in and get you really were
supposed to get the designated tattoos
they had but they did me a solid and did
like some whatever and they were but
they were free and seeing past no no I
paid oh okay okay yeah everybody had to
pay but anyway
um and I got tattooed like with the ice
on my knee and I thought my knee was
going to be bad because my knee hurts so
bad dude and it was so wobbly and then I
and I finished the tattoos and I stood
up and I was like my knee doesn't hurt
at all anymore
and Brittany the girl was tattooing me
he was very cool she was like does
anything hurt and I go my side kind of
hurts but I think it'll be okay and then
I went and crashed Legion of skanks
and I got on stage at legionist Kinks
and I was sitting and talking and I was
going like this I was going so anyway
got
like that because it started doing like
the cramp up sure sure
and I immediately after I left Legion of
skanks that was fun Whitney was there
she came in and we had fun yeah Houston
yeah back from the dead Cummings for
Halloween yeah Whitney Cummings was
there it was fun man uh anyway we we
hung out for a while on that on on
skanks and then skanks ended and I had
to do the Comedy Jam that night oh and I
called Josh and I go bro I don't think I
can sing dude I can't do this he's like
bro you can sing it's got to be fine
dude
and the medic found me the medic got me
he gave me um Aleve he's like you can
take four leave that'll help until you
can get so you can get prescription
stuff and put these patches on they're
like a step above Bengay and I did and I
felt good enough
and I did The Comedy Jam to sing what I
did time in my life from Dirty Dancing
wow there's always a hit and dude I
liked it right I'm sure everybody was
singing Jay Becky Rodriguez came on
stage Jay did the lift with her it was
it was right off no they tried it three
how was this special
awesome yeah yeah it was great for it I
saw I saw a lot of the first taping okay
and then I had to go do what does the
room look like what does space look like
it was it
did the skanks logo behind him which
looked really cool it was like litten
like
it looked really cool very well with the
room
hundreds I don't know how many totals
I'm just wondering if it's intimate or
not you know it was
sort of intimate but sort of not like
you know what I mean like it was well I
already had it very early in the day to
avoid everyone being blackout drunk he
did he did like a 1pm and a 4 P.M and he
did great and and Ari was worked on it
with him every it was awesome great the
whole thing was so much fun and just
seeing everybody bonding
bonding with people I haven't seen in a
while hung out with Nick Vatterott for a
while I haven't seen him in a while he's
great we were just hanging out this was
in Vegas Vegas yeah so what were you
contained to skank Fest right no one did
like Vegas
no one like went like no we would leave
it was in downtown Vegas we would leave
and go gamble and stuff oh you would
yeah Sean Patton was there okay hiring
with Sean panelott
um yeah we were all gambling Shane
Gillis was there six is there I was at
the Golden Nugget it was a blast yeah
yeah big Swede at the Golden Nugget is
that where the everybody was
half of us were gold nugget half of us
were Circa they're right across the
street from each other Circa yeah yeah
they're right across the street circus
no Circa right across the street on
Fremont Street okay yeah and then um the
venue was called I think notoriety
dude it was a blast it was an absolute
blast like you know
um do you have any Stevo yelled at me on
stage that was wild yelled at you I was
doing what's your [ __ ] deal it was
the audience Mike yeah and it was kind
of weird because the audience had to
stand because of the venue so I couldn't
like easily get into the audience the
way we usually do it okay
because nobody was seated so I had to
like kind of stay on stage and like if
if somebody wanted to talk to somebody
to like kind of jump off and run to the
it was it was com and he was the first
guy up
and like and he he did Apollo he hugged
me and apologized but he did yell at me
tell me the context tell me
he Siva was someone I'd never met I
tried telling him before we went on what
was going to happen and he was kind of
like go Dad cool cool and I was like
thanks
and I just remember as she was
she was like he's not listening and he's
not
he he's just not listening and then he
was first
and I was like yeah this is gonna be a
thing and he came on stage and he
started kind of like talking about how
he doesn't really do crowd work anymore
and he started telling some stories
that's not how you do it and it was I
don't say this to be shitty I I know
because I've done it so many times like
you can't start getting into store yeah
what's the format of the show for the
audience it's just crowd work you
interact with the audience it's 100
crowd work yeah and they got one comic
in the audience with a mic to be able to
so everyone there's a crowd work Mike
that's out there the whole time I was
the crowd work guy I always do it for
Jay when when I can and uh Jay hosts it
and sorry I should have explained it
okay yeah yeah so you're like the altar
boy of the show yeah you're out there
the whole time it's wild uh so I was
trying to tell Stephen that's how it's
going to go and he was just like yeah
yeah and then like he came on stage
first I was like oh boy he's not seeing
how this we do it and we're dealing with
all these weird factors because
everybody's standing and all this stuff
I was just standing behind him because I
was like he's not he said he doesn't
want to do crime I don't know what to do
and he was like he whipped he took his
dick out at one point nice
how was it I saw it up close it was good
good yeah it was nice but he turned to
me why he
because he's Stevo
yeah but still what's the context I
forget to be honest my head was kind of
racing because okay I was like I don't
know what to do right now okay weird
anyway he took he was challenging the
audience like people in the arms come
out and take their dick out and then he
was like I'll do it first and then he
took his dick out
and he turned to me
I said something and he turned to me and
he was like yeah dude she's supposed to
be out of here [ __ ] helping me man
and I'm [ __ ] bombing dude like I'm
asking you to take your [ __ ] dick out
and you won't do it and I go
straight out this is my first
interaction ever with Stevo yeah a man
I've greatly admired for much of my life
in my dick out and he goes no [ __ ] dude
and I go [ __ ] I'm out here to
try to help you you're not [ __ ]
talking but what do you want me to do
dude and he's like yeah well if I could
take your dick but and I was like all
right and I go who wants to take your
dick out and I got some people to come
up and do it
and then Steve and this was what like I
think broke the ice and bond us a little
bit
Stevo he was like laughing at the guys
taking their dicks out and then he goes
he goes I'm actually not a confident
dude I'm really insecure and I go really
because you seem pretty [ __ ]
confident when you came at me you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and uh and he started
laughing and he's like I'm sorry I'm
sorry and then when he was leaving the
stage he hugged me like privately and
was like dude I didn't mean to yell at
you I was just trying to be funny I'm
really really and I was like it's okay
it's okay it's okay but so it's fine but
at that moment it was [ __ ] very
awkward yeah I was like what am I it's
easy to bomb that show too yeah it's
easy one of my [ __ ] comedy Heroes is
yelling at me right now that's funny you
know or not hero you know what I mean
though like a guy that I really like
bombing with your dick out though I feel
for Stevo he wasn't once the dick
started coming out was fine he wasn't
bombing with his dick out he just was
his story what like you said the stories
don't work yeah especially first because
they said it's gonna be a crowd Show
crowd work show and he was telling you
I'm not saying it to knock him not in
any way trying to be inflammatory it was
all good it was just a very funny story
uh and then pepitone came out second and
pepitone was [ __ ] level the place
dude it was so many people in the
audience were clearly on drugs and I I
went into the audience Republican was
just standing in there amongst people
and
P I said it at a daddy at one point I go
dude the Collision of your comedy versus
the people on drugs in this audience is
so funny because people around me I just
kept hearing them go what the [ __ ] dude
because having its own this version of
crowd work he would be like he'd be like
have you ever seen a cat in a window and
your wife wants you to look and you say
who gives a [ __ ] people are starving
it was so insane dude and I was laughing
so [ __ ] and he goes but he asked me
that he goes if you see the cat in the
window I go I don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about and he goes you're
here to help me
he opened with the dicks
because he followed the Dick's thing he
opened with he goes I for one thought
that routine should have went 20 minutes
longer it didn't go long enough
dude it was that's great it was a
[ __ ] wild wild it was crazy that's
right did you stop by the naked roast
battle I always wanted to see that no I
had zero interest in a naked roast
battle no offense to anybody but
uh I I'm not a big look I was there by
default for the dicks coming out on
stage I'm not going to purposefully go
look at Dicks on stage your loss yeah
foreign
I know that sounds like I'm above it
which I am
but but no I didn't
think you're above
um King of the Segways you did that
segue on the last one too
steal the [ __ ] babe
we're well into this yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah all right all right but
maybe you want to know our friend had
what we did with his weekend I did for
40 minutes I'm just trying to help us
we're just trying to get to the battle
will you give me that hat forever oh no
no no right you wear now no I want it
forever uh it's one of my favorite hats
give it to me and I don't know if it's
available anymore you know where to get
one give it to me truly I bought this
years ago I don't know if they still
sell if they still sell it if they still
sell I'll buy you one
this is one of the only hats I own that
you couldn't have if you just if you ask
I have asked for it in the past no way
yeah no way no I asked for it and you
said no I'm not ready to part with this
are you serious yeah you were giving me
a hat for some reason I you said just
pick one you can keep it I said I like
that one you said I'm not ready to party
Don Jameson told me that's the thing he
would do when that metal show was on the
air he said fans would come up to it he
would go can I have your watch no just
give it to me sometimes it goes just to
see if they would do it he goes
sometimes they did no way
that's insane anyway all right ready
here we go oh wait are we doing a chant
you don't have it in you what's worse I
don't think we're gonna get too heated
all right how about no matter what
happens all right no I think well that's
foreign
you look better now than you do without
wearing the hot dog costume okay
okay ready yes
a hamburger suit added zero girth to
your body you just filled it out
filled it out
that was a good one
all right ready
here we go all right what's worse you
haven't get this out of there yeah
what's worse the Almond Joy or the Three
Musketeers I guess we should hold their
perspectives right that we're repping
I'm repping the Three Musketeer no no
you got this backwards bro give me the
thing I hate we're doing worse I I can't
this is as I said to V before we started
this is Nana candy there it this is
Disco it's a disgrace that somebody took
coconut the worst of all fruits there's
no worse fruit than coconut and this is
chocolate around it and said there you
go there's your candy bar that was the
Mounds and then they just described the
Mounds and then you go guys you go guys
really this is all I get and they go
almonds it's one almond per thing oh my
gosh that's one big ass almond let me
tell you something right now you're
adorable you're gonna lose on that
because just in and of itself by default
the Mounds is not as good as the Almond
Joy so you should have went Mounds
we only had an Almond Joy and you said
you love it Almond Joy and I said I hate
it I honestly do I think an Almond Joy
is I I don't I don't hate amounts but I
think an Almond Joy is think about this
to me is the worst this is this is why
this is worse than I'm enjoy ready the
ad the adaptation of the Almond is an
insult it's like when you leave a tip
but you leave like a dollar but the bill
was like fifty dollars it would have
been better just not to leave a tip
that's not what it is
a flavor combination that already
existed in Mounds which I also like and
saying what's a way to elevate this in
an understate a way that will give it a
whole new flavor profile and it works
okay I understand what you mean by
banana candy because I don't know I I
think Mounds would I think you'd be
surprised at how many people like Almond
Joy I don't think coconut is the worst I
like coconut coconut is very versatile
coconut you know coconut shrimp you can
have coconut coconut shrimp infuriate me
you're taking something as wonderful as
the fried shrimp and adding this
sweetness to it that doesn't need to be
there coconut shrimp can take a hike I
like coconut flavor in one or two things
here or there but it's got to be
something in addition to something else
coconut is never ever and I mean ever
never the star of the show for you to
put coconut as the star of the show is
insane because it works what do you mean
why would you say it's not the star of
the show when in Almond Joy it is in an
almond joint amounts I mean it is the
Almond you know what I see what I see
this it's actually delicious that that
coconut in there is I'm gonna taste it
today but you know what I see when I see
this I see something that I think is
going to taste like a York Peppermint
pan body and then it's not and I don't
know why you think that because it's it
looks exactly the same when you bust it
open did you ever bust so show us an
open Mint I know it looks exactly the
same though yeah not really when you
open up it almost more texture the the
Batman Patty is is like almost like a
light cream
I don't know open up an Almond Joy I
mean there's okay so there's The
Peppermint Patty right the Almond Joy
you can see the coconut look how we
spell the almond
see you see that but it looks like it's
gonna they're both white I guess ugh
look at that they get here too they put
the two notes right on top
it looks like a growth ew look at it I
think it's cool instead of burying it in
there I like how they they say two full
nuts to a half and I like how they put
it on top and then let the chocolate
rain down and then just stiffen and you
have the two and then when you bite it
you know exactly where to bite I like it
I just can't think of anything worse if
you're gonna fill up a vacuum of
chocolate with something I can't think
of anything worse than coconut outside
of the strawberry cream that you get in
those candy boxes
let me actually use your own argument
against you if I may okay
[Laughter]
isn't it
you're like how do you put uh coconut in
a chocolate wait can I say my favorite
line for that episode when Seinfeld goes
I hate my guy he's a mean guy all right
sorry when they're babysitting the older
people yeah the old guy that baby that
he is is so good yeah would be getting
rid of it then would I Einstein that
guy's so awesome anyway go ahead sir I
want to use your argument against you
you're like how do you take something
like coconut and put it in a chocolate
bar well I will tell you this
they're the only ones that do it and for
me that makes it extra special there's
not a version of Almond Joy if you want
coconut in a bar you're getting man's
Ramen joint if you want a nut and
coconut a bar that's your One-Stop shop
there's no other one whereinas we just
said the Baby Ruth is the exact
ingredients as the Snickers everybody's
playing the same game they got chocolate
they got nuts they got I've seen array
of candy bars here and I see an array of
uh different flavors and textures and
ingredients caramel nougat chocolate
butter peanut butter
peanut butter this is
caramel this is Cookie don't rule out
cookie it's caramel but yeah but there's
cookies I'm just saying dude this is
almonds and chocolate this is almonds
and chocolate throw me that throw me
looking thickness throw me stickers
caramel caramel caramel caramel
caramel okay okay wait wait yeah there's
a reason for that nougat nougat nougat
nougat okay there's a reason for that
I'll tell you why
you put down you put six you put six
cheeseburgers from six different
cheeseburger restaurants next to each
other
ketchup ketchup ketchup ketchup cheese
yeah there's a reason for that those are
the things that make a burger taste
awesome those are the things the
everything you're naming is what makes a
candy bar taste awesome and once in a
while you'll go that's the only burger
place that puts uh uh
head cheese on a burger or whatever some
goofy thing that nobody else does and
you go yeah cause it sucks like I don't
want that that's a real dumb one that's
the one burger place that actually puts
peanut butter on their burgers and it
sucks I'll let you speak the whole time
it was a dumb argument no it's not it is
no it's not saying there's like four or
five main ingredients that every candy
bar goes off of outside of chocolate and
I'm saying if you want caramel in your
bar you got 100 options if you want
Kalam peanuts you still have 100 options
if you want nougat you got 100 options
some of them are [ __ ] identical that
is a one of one Solomon Joy is a broker
my point is my point is is I'll make
I'll make the argument make more sense
with the burger analogy you'll find one
burger place that puts bananas on the
burger and they'll go it's called the
Elvis get it and you go okay it sucks I
don't want that and there will be a
handful of people that tell you dude
that's the best burgers that ever
existed and you just don't know what
you're talking about because bananas are
good and you you it's the same thing
you're talking about I don't believe
that is there's a reason
these flavors go together they do go
together
I'm not saying that coconut and
chocolate don't go together I am saying
coconut is not the star of that show you
better put some other [ __ ] into that mix
this is coming from you who doesn't like
coconut there is a cake one hold on I
already no no you can't do that you
can't do that by the way at skank Fest
it was pointed out to me many times that
you do this to me I said
five minutes ago I don't dislike coconut
it's just not the star of the show
called coconut the absolute worst fruit
there is it is doesn't mean I don't like
it
would I eat coconut
it
is
you're gonna and then I said
I said you don't like coconut and you
say whoa whoa I didn't say that and
everybody had skunked because I said
because I said to you right after that I
don't I don't dislike coconut flavor and
things I don't like coconut I don't
dislike coconut things I like it in
things but it's not the star of the show
it can't be the most it is in this Barn
it works I no but you're wrong I
disagree people like Almond Joy talk
about why the Three Musketeers is bad it
[ __ ] is the worst candy bar in the
world there's two ingredients there's
two ingredients okay and we don't even
know what the hell that other ingredient
is do you know what it's called on the
packaging whipped no it's not no it's
not it's called whipped up fluffy
chocolate taste
that's what's in the middle whipped up
fluffy time this tried to go sit
everywhere it says
throw it to me don't show me from a crow
over there
read it out loud Woody glasses no that's
not listed as an ingredient see I knew
that's what he was doing and that's why
he has to see it it's saying that's
their description of the candy bar
whipped up fluffy chocolate taste it
doesn't say that that is an ingredient
I knew you were lying hold on let's see
what it is
nuke it no nuket is not one of the
ingredients it was new to it bro it
would say because nougat isn't it
doesn't say nuke it on a Snickers bar
ingredients either you can't call nougat
an ingredient what are you nuts that's
what it says in the side part in the
description nuke it's not going to be
they're gonna write on the backwards
this is this feels like just uh they
tried something with little effort
I let you speak go ahead okay do
you know when we were little like those
Hershey packs they sold many many bags
and these were the two in it the Milky
Way and the Three Musketeers and you
always take the Milky Way over it
because it was better ingredients and it
was a better combination of ingredients
Musketeers is like what's the littlest
effort I can do I don't even know that
thing in the middle is not good that
it's just like fluffy chocolate nothing
covered in chocolate it's not you know
what's going on with this bar there's no
excitement they've never ever deviated
in any way they've never shown me
anything that is like just a bit
Innovative they didn't need to it's it's
old hat neither of these everything
you're saying applies to this I will
tell you right now everything right now
in outside of convenience okay and we
can't and we watched for one week people
walk in and get chocolate I guarantee
you no one is walking in off the street
and selecting The Three Musketeers that
they're paying for as their number one
choice of beginner but I will do it with
an Almond Joy
just like you don't like that there's
people that say I love it and there's
nowhere else to get it and they're
die-hards old person who can't chew
things probably goes same as this buddy
this is so I think kids love the three
muskets no kids love this it's a huge
joke it's like even the name is like a
hundred-year-old it's a huge Halloween
candy bar it's a staple at Halloween
with Kitty this never is this ever got
this in my house
the Almond is a prestigious nut and
that's in there and coconut is also
prestigious and that's in there this is
nothing this is [ __ ] you just sit in the
lower box you're all over the place
you're all over the place you said kids
don't like that that's [ __ ] and I
said that's a staple Halloween candy
this is not kids do like absolutely it's
mounds and Almond Joy minis are staple
in the bag they are staple just like
this they both are I'm not saying this
is not but this is the most
underwhelming candy bar there is I've
never been excited to have one if there
was one on the table you're just all
hanging out I would be like I don't all
three musketeers I propose nothing I
wouldn't eat it because it's not good
the chocolate isn't good enough to
sustain itself it's not like when you
bite into like a really good chocolate
one like this chocolate is delicious the
chocolate is and chocolate and the
middle is and there's nothing to it it's
a one-two combination when you think
Simplicity was gonna be on this side and
it's bad it's a bleeding candy bar
boring as all but it's a leading candy
bar s
I know and as I've said every argument
you're making applies to your candy bar
hold on hold on what do you like about
this Joe what do you like about it it's
a chocolate flavor with a chocolate
moussey texture on the inside that has a
slightly different chocolate flavor it's
a good chocolate flavor you and that's
it you would say that this candy bar is
good that candy bar reminds me of a of a
fast
of a I'm gonna say fast food because
candy bars are the fast food of candy
right they're they're they're not
they're not why are you rolling your
eyes I can't make sense of what you're
saying you can't make sense of the fact
that candy bars are a cheap quick fast
version of Quality Candy what's Quality
Candy like you're not getting like
Baker's [ __ ] fudge when you buy a
candy bar you're not getting truly made
Italian cookies you know what I'm saying
if you go to an Italian Shop in Brooklyn
and they make homemade candy that's a
much higher quality candy than M M's I
wouldn't like it instead of fast food
candy okay it's convenience store food
is that good enough sure yeah there you
go kind of like fast food weird anyway
uh
it's convenience store it's a
convenience store version of something
but I would say that's almost like a
chocolate mousy a convenience store I
understand you don't like coconut in
that you're gonna you're gonna also
you're gonna stick up for this it is a
convenience store version of a chocolate
mousse type of experience yes that's
what I always think it's about when I
eat that I mean you just gotta go to the
phones by the way we'll go to the phone
for now we'll go on the phone well did
you did you know what you say when I'm
ready we'll go to the phones when I'm
done making my point oh okay did you
almost tell you we're gonna say yeah
pimp thinks I need to go to the phones
oh we got your number you had that
sharkling kid fooled last week with your
nice guy routine here's the real [ __ ]
Sal hey Tom I hope you're watching
here's the real Sal you're a big just
steaming windbag of negativity
Big Win bag of negativity that likes to
shout and you you will you will latch on
to an argument when it serves you even
if you don't believe it and just now I'm
gonna watch you take a bite of a Three
Musketeers I enjoy that you lie to our
to our family have them try it have them
try it I watched you lie I enjoyed it I
know that even if you don't like the
Almond Joy you can't bite into a Three
Musketeers and look at us with a
straight hot dog face and tell me that
that was enjoyable because it's the most
plain underlying forgettable nothing
enjoyed it you don't even know what the
ingredients are I didn't um enjoy that
the nerve that they put joy in the title
of this candy bar the nurse in the title
there you go three musketeers
somebody try it why is it even called a
Three Musketeers
all right huh why is it called The Three
Musketeers it's it's maybe legendary
literary characters they're trying to
get the kids to read
that's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard
well look it up I don't know why it's
called that an old Literary story and
naming it after the candy bar these are
three people that fight with fencing
1932 it came in a box that had three
mini candy bars in it oh like V said one
was strawberry one was chocolate and one
was vanilla and the other two got
complete action so they went full
chocolate eventually okay that's why
pretty much can I can I just see wait
what is what is the thing in the middle
can we can we find that out what is the
thing in the chocolate nougat for
Christ's sake yes I don't know if it is
what else would it be Sal why wouldn't
it just say nougat
because they're trying to make it sound
different nougat chocolate Center Christ
almighty made by whipping eggs creating
a frappe or similar to [ __ ] what I
was saying
anyway can we go to the phone sure I
just wish now I'm gonna walk away from
this episode though knowing you're
you're a phony baloney why you like
Meryl Streep
what if you're quoting Seinfeld you
don't know that one yeah she was fine
you go over that coffee I'm getting
nervous look at me I just think you're
phony because I know that you didn't
think that that was great and you
pretended like it was I liked it I took
two bites I didn't take two bites out of
any other candy bar except the payday I
liked it
why can't you accept me there's nothing
there's nothing there's nothing why
can't you let me be me there's nothing
to a three musketeers wait that's a
funny thing to say when you're wearing a
hot why won't you let me beat me
nobody's holding you back yeah I don't
know all right to the phone it's I I
think the Three Musketeers is embodies
you know why you like it
the one word I would use what's the one
word you would use to describe any candy
bars like delicious delicious
delicious chocolatey this is great [ __ ]
you know how I would describe that first
before anything else boring yeah you've
made that point Seventeen no I didn't
say boring yeah you did you said you've
used different words we get your points
it's appropriate that that you like that
because it's just oh yeah because you
know me I'm such a bore it's just a
plain old boring thing yeah yeah you
know me just a simple life I don't do
anything crazy yeah you're a real
[ __ ] boy all right I'm gonna start
calling you three musketeers from now on
okay you're an underwhelming boar all
right all right did you get your last
words in you happy you satisfied big man
you're getting the last words in all
right go ahead
people who don't like coconut never been
on a beach vacation and it shows there
you go you can set it yourself well
that's I'm reading the things he can't
afford vacations that are not domestic
all right
three muskets that's funny to make fun
of somebody's welfare that's really
funny that's good is always a safe
choice if you're looking for chocolate
Almond Joys are for old stirrers and
people who think nacho cheese just too
spicy I don't get that
they put joy in the name because it's
nowhere to be found in the candy might
drop Three Musketeers can walk right
into that ditch Joe loved so much there
you go if you pick Three Musketeers
you're either under 13 years old or have
diabetes one contains a nut and the
other makes me bust a nut
really for me I could take her leave the
Almond the Almond Joys for coconut
chocolate combo that I eat and enjoy
every time I eat
with three musketeers I feel horrible
after there you go
out
I'll pass on the coconut turret any time
um almond Jewish Three Musketeers remind
me of sticky poop mixed with belly
button lint it needs to back up
uh oh uh pretty much here's the trailer
Clear Choice almost as disappointing as
the real Three musket
supposed Heroes for the people were
actually just three perverts cause okay
wait I don't get that that sentence goes
it's a pro and con for Three Musketeers
in the same sentence no there's he said
the candy boys is disappointing as the
real Three Musketeers the real Three
Musketeers weren't actually Heroes I
guess I don't know coconuts man its own
added to chocolate and magical things
happen wait we can just go up a little
bit Almond Joy is grateful when you need
to squirt out a week of heavy drinking
and truck use okay after scaring Fest
that's interesting
dang I read it wrong I voted Almond Joy
is the worst oh see see hey man how much
I thought that people you know you you
got to not click immediately shut your
goddamn mouth almond Joy's the delicious
all caps Three Musketeers is 80 air and
100 [ __ ] I couldn't agree with you more
that fluffy air too in there they're
getting full price for a candy bottle
the only joy I get out of Almond Joy is
giving them the kids on Halloween
knowing I had a key part in ruining
their festivities Three Musketeers is
garbage even a mini is too damn useless
disgusting fluff I need to public
apologize to the Milky Way bar I used to
think it was the same thing no not at
all they should call it almond suffering
Three Musketeers is actually one of my
favorites but I love them Frozen that's
a great Point Frozen Three Musketeers is
great
this is uh this is split man I don't
know who's gonna win I know I would say
the win is the ditch comment no just
because it's I mean it's inside baseball
but they're all good huh you could pick
who uh the Almond Joy I would give it me
personally I would put I would pick they
gave they put joy in the name because
they're short so let's give it to both
of those a pro-joy and a conjoy so
follow Devin Johnson 44
and follow Shelton underscore Buell
which is spelled b-u-e-l-l okay
uh our plugs are at the top of the show
please buy merch Please Subscribe please
uh like the video it helps a lot right
yes subscribe and follow us on iTunes uh
yeah Radisson iTunes and follow us on
all the social media platforms here we
go 7 000 votes oh this is so wait wait
wait wait wait wait which is worse so
whoever has more loses
Whoever has the higher percentage here
loses right because you're voting which
one is worse so if yes right okay so I'm
hoping that Three Musketeers has a
higher percentage in Almond Joy which
made me just think of something but I'll
tell you after okay I think well a lot I
saw three people say I accidentally
clicked Almond Joy the higher the best
the higher wins
I mean the lower winds
so I win
oh that's crazy 55 Almond Joy is the
worst kid wow
that was very close I'm shocked I'm
shocked no I am shocked you're shocked
come on dude this is at least something
original
they started to make a candy bar and
stopped they left everything so I get
that it's original but when you're
growing you're and then we'll we gotta
rap but when you're growing up
when you think back to the candy works
for growing up Almond Joy is not in in
the mix Three Musketeers is not easy yes
it is it's not no it was one of the ones
that was there as part of the party does
not excite any child you know what I'm
saying I swear to God it's like you know
what it's like it's like the first candy
bar ever before they realized they could
put all the stuff in it yeah yeah keep
keep making that point over and over
again I made it once eight seconds ago
and I clarified it yeah yeah no I know
you you I guess it's boring right you're
dressed like a hot dog bro I know it's
Halloween I know get in the spirit you
you you are a [ __ ] human hot dog
I love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food